hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the slender
the arrival beta now I was actually
surprised that this came out so soon
because I thought it was still a ways
off I didn't even know there was a
release date or a beta coming but you
can go to the website which is in the
description below click the link it'll
take you to the beta website and you can
pre-order the game for $5 and get access
to the beta now and then get the game
when it comes out so check that out if
you want and here we go ok now I'm not
exactly sure a lot of what they added to
the game other than that it's um I think
it's still on the unity engine I believe
but also outside Park has three canoes
available for intro oh that I'm zooming
in the camera with E I thought the e was
you button but apparently not okay so hi
okay I know for a fact that there are
other entities in this game besides of
Slenderman I think they have mask e in
here and if you've read any of the
original creepypastas or lore about
Slenderman you know the Marble Hornets
videos they're all involved in connected
so I think this particular game is more
true to the original Marne the Marble
Hornets videos which aren't the original
thing about Slenderman but anyway I
think I see a note there I'm not sure if
this game is about note collecting or
what because the intro kind of said
survival is up to you use what you know
yep that is a note alright one of eight
pages collected so maybe the beta is
more about the original Slender than
anything
oh the old familiar music
yeah might just be a display of the
engine and kind of repeating the same
game because the intro music was the
exact same as the other one okay let's
see what we got here obviously it's a
different island it's not an island it's
a different location might as well be an
island it's definitely got a familiar
feel to it I definitely know that I'm
playing a slender game I mean it's good
to finally because this is made by the
original guys that made the original
Slender game now they didn't come up
with the slender legend but they at
least made the first real game that
caught on with everybody and that's a
good thing because when this is released
this is going to be an actual real full
game made by an actual game speed is
called blue Isle and blue Isle
productions I believe okay there's a
second note okay I believe this man
building might be analogous to the
building that was at first any other
area let's get the hell on earth
I mean not much else to say other than
going into the forest looking for pages
which is a pretty familiar game I do
like the locale the level of details if
people add into these games are much
appreciate because you get a lot of
these indie horror games from people in
they're kind of just ramshackle and
everything in a lot of ways I'm kind of
ah oh oh hello that's different okay so
yeah he's over there holy hell wait
while I got a look at this park there's
a pager yeah go away please
okay so yeah that was different that was
much different it was it was um it was
an evolution of the general static
pattern that appears when you look at
him it was like my whole vision was
actually twerking around okay why is
here did someone really need to go to
the bathroom not bad that they needed a
flare to mark it out just in case you
needed to come back okay I've got four
pages I'm not really not doing so bad
then again the difficulty is only on
normal I believe so Slenderman is now
out there ready to nibble on meri why
are they
let me up let me up where is he where is
he where up go I go I go I go I go I go
I go I okay we're now knee-deep in the
[ __ ]
all right so huh he's right behind me
I'm not gonna look back because that's
that's a big that's a big mistake I
always make it Sunderman games I'm like
her but let's look backwards
Oh No he wasn't there lady check again
maybe he'll pop up eventually I know
he's here I just have this really bad
habit of looking backwards I I'm
recording thing so I want you guys to be
able to see what's trying to kill me
wait no all done this is back at the
beginning this way ah ha ha ha I did it
again I did it again what's up here or
is this just back where I was like that
I don't like the new the new Slenderman
getcha stuff there's nothing here it's
just a fence isn't it I just went into
the woods
these cotton plants not sure what these
are
can't see though sad over there I see
you a red light I can't turn there all
these damn ha yeah
huh oh he's blocking my exit I can't see
where I'm going through all these damn
plants wait was it that something is
that some no it's a wood post ah did I
just see a face on my flashlight or
something I could've sworn I saw
something else like her saw Sunderman
and then I saw something me ah sobbing
Jesus Christ you're gonna give me a
heart attack trying to survive here
I hear stomping through the woods is
that Slenderman getting closer to me
okay so I already went that way try to
get the pages at the building and the
outhouse and I think the Slenderman was
blocking another pass up north I really
do like the ways like there's a lot of
attention to detail in this game if I
could just get away from being scared
for a moment like the trees swaying in
the wind that's that that's a small
detail that a lot of people wouldn't add
but it really adds the immersion what is
that there's a spotlight up on the hill
over there I'm not sure what it is oh no
oh yeah there's another page it's
different it's water tower okay so are
there are various landmarks in this
little area I think I'm pretty sure now
ah [ __ ]
I'm pretty sure now that the beta is
just kind of up it's not actually the
full game where you know the the whole
game is built around the Sun Oven mythos
and um there's a lot more immersion - I
think the beta is just kind of a
quote-unquote remake of the original
eight pages which is cool anyway because
it's still really good I'm sure this
will be included uh god it's a maze
where it's a damn page I'm gonna die
that's how I die this is where I die
don't tell me I got ears oh come on
where I said where'd you go ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha I got it
I'm going away now this phone this wrote
out don't kill me look at your mother
live for wait a minute that's sign it's
got Slenderman on it now that wasn't
there before I'll back you okay I wanted
to circle I want that circle dancer
going with that circle I don't know her
God ah all right what happens is ill let
me go on the beach side just oh no no
yes no they've been go up through here
yes no all right oh this point where I
just got Wow pick up I've acted ah God
right here
Oh God
running running guy please oh uh uh I
thought that would pose all that
startled but hate oh come on
oh there's gotta be another page
maybe there's another one in that
building over there there had to be one
by that Watchtower right how do we
it's another landmark they've gotta be
there he's gotta be there where is he
ride a bike hey big hey bigger
is he getting taller hi screaming oh I
think he's getting taller which is weird
I'm moving why is that supposed to be a
little ha ha my eyes I said why does in
who's there my top eight it's a look at
seven where's the last [ __ ] one I
don't know hello Amy Weber
maybe on the outside of the building
please
somewhere anywhere
Oh God opps elbow
I'm cellphone maybe there's another one
in this building somewhere maybe there's
two in the building goes the only other
lame are gonna die
oh come on don't let me die don't let me
down I dun da-dun not seven pages I've
never painted up you dumb [ __ ]
viola I'm gonna go get a room I've sell
boat how's our boat that's how about I'm
so about I'm solid
there's no other bait in you auto mode
I'm sorry
maybe now I can go to the beach that's
my only chance that's the only thing I
know could possibly be it maybe now I go
to the beach wait what's this oh oh is
this what's this what's this
what that's there's nothing
ah there's nothing here I can't spare a
bar there was nothing there oh there
might have been something I didn't look
hard enough oh oh that had to be
something database out like there
not out out out out no no
no no no no no no the guys over here I'm
gonna double-check it does it be sure
not fairy butter right in front of me is
trying to keep me wait for the page I
gotta go down baby no I don't know I
don't know I don't know let me go down
to the beach house
baby is there no thought about that
Slenderman this is nothing beach house
it's really tall now he's like hot uh-uh
can't breath anymore
maximum sprinter dude reached I was in
him that was alight Oh God yeah you
can't be that tall what am I thinking
you're not that tall he's not that tall
right you can't possibly be that maybe
there's something about that eye right
oh god he'd like right there are some
boat hugs elbowed beach house don't be
fenced up you [ __ ] I'll chill mode
hotel boat oh [ __ ] me boy it's gotta be
in those rocks it's gotta be in those
rocks it's gotta be it's gotta be
there's no other place - come on I'll
get another tribe there's no other place
to can possibly be no other place it
could possibly be there's no other place
Hey
go away please leave me alone
where'd the rocks go where are the rest
those rocks those are the rocks it's got
to be in here this is the only other
landmark that exists in this place I
can't believe I overlooked it at first
but it's gotta be in here on the ground
maybe somewhere on the walls I got to
see it where is it where is it it's not
here Oh are you okay all right it's not
there it's not there it's not there it's
not there it's not there it's not there
it's popped by an hour Wow
hit everyone I'll lose him in the
building again god damn it won't leave
me alone
he won't leave me alone you only Mila I
don't know where to go man I don't know
where to go there's no other place that
it could be non the bathroom's no but
ghosts oh it's gotta be somewhere okay
the only other place I could think to
check maybe is up behind the cargo
containers I think there was a little
bit of an area back there let me just
cut through these rocks one more time
just to check cuz I would kick myself it
was actually here but it doesn't seem
like it is
okay I don't seem to have any limit on
my sprint so come on it's gotta be here
it's got it's got to be here oh it's
gotta be here it's like a glow coming
from up there let me check what is that
what is that oh wow I love gloves what
is it suppose it'll do happy does it
have a page that's a badge yes I got it
I think I did it who is so weird
I think I got it I did it
maybe I'm not sure cuz it was it was
like that complete silence that old said
I guess but around I got stuck on a tree
but I don't think it would about it
because they're just like win ah oh man
that was incredible oh man and my heart
pumping so far oh oh man that was
incredible oh it's so good to finally
have the the guy who made the original
Slender the original great thing and I'm
sorry for screaming so much I overloaded
my mic so much oh that was that was
fantastic that was fantastic all of you
kids should go out and this is like this
this isn't itself gonna be the full game
the full game is gonna be much more
actually gonna have a story and be like
a full game this was just the beta which
was like a remake of um the UH the
original sunder the a pages so thank you
all so much for watching click the link
in the description below to go to the
website and pre adored for yourself it's
gonna be amazing
I can tell so thank you everybody so
much watching click the annotation for
more video looks give me that was so
rude of me
for more video said I've done and as
always I will see
in the next video by